- Are you guys having fun?
- [Both] Yeah!
- It's hot.
- It's so hot.
- It's really hot.
- You're hot!
- It's so hot.
- Thank you!
(bouncy music)
- [All] Yay!
(upbeat music)
- [Jooe] Whoa!
- World star!
- [Girl] Oh my god, me!
(bell chiming)
(mystical music)
- It's the uniform.
- [Jane] I think I want the scarf.
Or a wand.
I need a wand.
(bell chiming)
- Wingardium leviosa
- Okay.
(Frog Choir singing)
(bell chiming)
(happy music)
(upbeat music)
- It's not working.
(bell chiming)
(goofy music)
- Are you guys ready?
3, 2, 1, fire!
Alright great job guys.
(bell chiming)
- Wow!
(upbeat music)
- [Ride Operator] Hello,
hello ladies and gentleman.
Welcome aboard the world
famous Studio Tour.
How is everybody doing?
- [All] Yeah!
- [Ride Operator] Guys we've
got ourselves a flash flood!
(all screaming)
- I love you!
(all laughing)
(bell chiming)
(all cheering)
- I love you!
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.